[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und marietta slomka guten abend der
stopps einer bundesministerin oder eines
ministers ist natürlich immer ein großer
politischer knall im falle von
familienministerin anders spiegel dürfte
sich der nachhall allerdings in grenzen
halten viel strahlkraft hatte sie in
diesem amt noch nicht entfalten können
kein vergleich etwa mit dem früheren
verteidigungsminister zu guttenberg an
dessen rücktritt man sich erinnert und
das nicht nur weil die nation seinerzeit
heftig darüber debattiert
der fall von eines spiegel wird wohl
weniger in die politischen
geschichtsbücher eingehen als denn
lehrbücher für kommunikationsprofis als
anschauungsunterricht dafür wie man es
nicht machen darf heute zog man bei den
grünen die reißleine nicole diekmann
berichtet
diese bilder und diese aufbruchsstimmung
sind gerade mal vier monate her und mit
dem heutigen tag geschichte nur vier
monate hielt sie sich an der spitze des
familienministeriums eines spiegel grün
jung mutter von vier kindern sie schien
die idealbesetzung doch heute endet
diese karriere mit einer
pressemitteilung
aufgrund des politischen drucks habe sie
entschieden ihr amt zur verfügung zu
stellen schreibt eine spiegel nichts
jedoch von fehlern anders als gestern da
hatte sie gesprochen auf äußerst
ungewöhnliche art und weise da auch von
fehlern von einem rücktritt jedoch nicht
das war ein fehler dass wir
auch so langen urlaub gefahren sind und
dass wir in urlaub gefahren sind
und ich bitte
für diesen fehler
um entschuldigung
eine ministerin die um fassung ringt um
worte um ihr politisches überleben und
dafür sogar privates an die
öffentlichkeit zerrt doch der versuchte
befreiungsschlag misslingt kurz nach der
flutkatastrophe mit vielen toten im
aartal vergangenen sommer bei spiegel
damals noch verantwortliche ministerin
in rheinland pfalz vier wochen lang in
urlaub gefahren und hatte überdies
zunächst fälschlicherweise behauptet aus
diesem urlaub heraus online an
kabinettssitzungen teilgenommen zu haben
heute vormittag aus ihrer partei zwei
worte des mitgefühls allerdings keine
zurückweisung der rücktrittsforderungen
was die pressekonferenz von einer
spiegel angeht würde ich für mich keine
für mich sagen dass sie unter die haut
gegangen ist das glaube ich ging also
dies gesehen haben und zu allen weiteren
fragen wird sich zeitnah der
bundesvorstand der grünen kader lang und
mit nouripour äußern vielen dank
währenddessen steigt hinter den kulissen
der parteiinterne druck auf spiegel den
beiden parteichefs bleibt am nachmittag
nur noch ihre entscheidung zu begrüßen
sichtlich geschockt und noch ohne
weiteren fahrplan der
schritt jetzt nun zurück zu treten ist
bei aller
großen herzen und so schwierig diese
entscheidung auch war richtig bitte sie
um verständnis dass gerade für uns erst
mal eine andere frage im zentrum steht
ich glaube ich gerade moment auch alle
mit anderen gedanken erstmal beschäftigt
sind aber wir werden zeitnah an
nachfolger ankündigen am abend tritt der
kanzler vor die presse anlass ist der
besuch des albanischen
ministerpräsidenten
natürlich wird olaf scholz auch nach dem
ersten rücktritt aus seinem kabinett
gefragt
jetzt sehr berührt was sie über sich
selber und ihre lebenssituation gestern
und heute geschildert hat und deshalb
hat ihre entscheidung
größten respekt verdient meinen hat sie
jedenfalls was dieser paukenschlag für
seine regierung bedeutet diese frage
beantwortet scholz nicht
nur vier monate sind diese bilder alt
die aufbruchsstimmung und die ampel als
sie und die grünen haben heute einen
empfindlichen dämpfer erlitten
zum rücktritt der ministerin nun ein
kommentar von redaktionsleiter des
heute-journals wulf schmiese
der rücktritt von bundesministerin eines
spiegel war unausweichlich
menschlich ist er eine tragödie weil
ausgerechnet die familienministerin
eingestehen musste mit der eigenen
familie überfordert gewesen zu sein
gehetzt und zerrissen zwischen den über
belastungen des amts und denen daheim
wie so viele eltern mit job und kindern
eltern überall in deutschland die nur
mühsam die fassade aufrecht erhalten das
sei alles auf einmal und mit links zu
schaffen weil sie wissen dass sie ihrer
karriere in gefahr bringen wenn sie
schwäche zeigen ja das ist hart und
ungerecht insbesondere für mütter
kleiner kinder doch in diesem speziellen
fall hätte dennoch klar sein müssen dass
amt geht vor die verantwortung während
der flutkatastrophe durfte eines spiegel
nicht delegieren und erst recht durfte
sie nicht lügen und ihren urlaub vor der
eigenen partei verheimlichen sie hat
alle getäuscht natürlich konnte sie nach
so einem vertrauensbruch nicht auf ihren
posten bleiben leider hat sie das selbst
viel zu spät ein gesehen nun hat sie
beruflich alles verloren da sie kein
abgeordnetenmandat hat mit ihrem
auftritt gestern hat eine spiegel
zumindest offenbart was viele empfinden
die karriere und kinder wollen heillose
überforderung wer immer ihre nachfolge
antritt sollte das nicht vergessen vor
allem für doppelt und dreifach belastete
eltern muss dringend mehr getan werden
so kommentierte und wir blicken in die
ukraine auf das was dort im moment
geschieht und auf das was für die
nächsten tage und wochen zu befürchten
ist dass die russische armee an kiew
gescheitert ist und sich aus dieser
region zurückziehen verheißt zugleich ja
leider unheilvolles für das was sie nun
im osten und süden des landes vor hat
putin wird dort nun erst recht und um
jeden preis fortschritte sehen wollen
die er seiner bevölkerung spätestens zu
den traditionellen feierlichkeiten am 9
mai präsentieren kann wenn in moskau wie
jedes jahr mit großen paraden an den
sieg über hitler-deutschland erinnert
wird in absurden vergleichen wird der
zweite weltkrieg ja auch für die
kriegstreiberei gegen die ukraine
herangezogen dominik löschmeister und ab
ginzel berichten knapp 13 kilometer lang
soll er sein der neue russische
militärkonvoi in der ost ukraine
es sind satellitenbilder des
amerikanischen unternehmens mixa 400
russische fahrzeuge sollen es sein auf
dem weg in den don bass vorbereitungen
für einen neuen großangriff
ich würde jetzt mal vermuten dass wir
in der woche noch sehen werden wo
truppen verstärkt werden und dann
sozusagen wird diese verstärkung
abgeschlossen sein und da kann im
prinzip der großangriffe jeden tag
erfolgen russlands armee hat sich aus
der umgebung von kiew und im norden der
ukraine zurückgezogen die angriffe
konzentrieren sich nun auf den osten und
den süden unter anderem auf rache und
mario pohl
von dort kommen diese bilder russische
panzer auf ihrem vormarsch die
prorussischen separatisten melden die
eroberung des hafens die ukrainische
seite betont die kämpfe um mario pohl
gingen weiter
willkommen in die situation dass beide
seiten quasi einen abnutzungskrieg
eintreten das heißt es hängt sehr davon
ab wieviel menschenmaterial beide seiten
nach führen können in dem kontext ist
auch die forderung die vehemente
forderung der ukraine mehr material und
besseres material aus dem westen zu
bekommen zu verstehen denn es geht darum
diesen angriff abzuwehren ein abnutzung
der vor allem die zivilbevölkerung
trifft 10.000 tote soll es in mario pohl
geben auch in kharkiv nehmen die kämpfe
zu in diesem wohnviertel ist eine rakete
eingeschlagen das einfamilienhaus völlig
zerstört eine straße weiter noch ein
einschlag der russische angriff hat
menschenleben gefordert
mein mann wurde getötet er saß auf einer
bank dann ist das geschoss angeschlagen
ich weiß nicht was es war
morgen sollten wir nachholen ausreisen
und das ist jetzt daraus geworden
westliche beobachter vermuten putins
ziel könnte sein schon anfang mai die
kontrolle über die ost ukraine zu
erlangen es wird entscheidend sein für
den russischen erfolg den man gerne am 9
mai programmieren möchte dass man nicht
nur das material hat sondern auch die
moral der soldatinnen und soldaten
gesteigert denn das ist neben der nimmt
den problemen den mann auf der material
sind auf der kommando seite gehabt hat
das andere problem zusätzlich können wir
nicht wissen wie sich im prinzip diese
neuerungen der waffenlieferung also wo
immer mehr schwereres gerät in die
ukraine kommt auf die kampffähigkeit der
ukrainischen streitkräfte aus wirkt also
es kann sein dass das in einem patt ende
60 tausend reservisten soll russland
einberufen haben für die neue offensive
die bereits an ostern starten konnte
angesichts der truppenbewegungen der
offenkundigen zerstörungswut und der
kriegstreiberischen rhetorik des kreml
ist im westen jedenfalls längst die
erkenntnis gereift dass die russen diese
schlachten noch lange weiterzuführen
gedenken und in der ukraine womöglich
nicht halt machen das zeigt ja in vieler
hinsicht wirkung die baltischen staaten
förder und verstärkung ihrer grenzen
durch die nato finnland und schweden
erwägen der nato beizutreten was
jahrzehntelang praktisch kein thema war
und der westen richtet sich darauf ein
die ukraine noch lange weiter mit waffen
auszustatten
das war auch thema beim treffen der eu
außenminister heute fragt sich ob solche
lieferungen für städte wie mario pohl
umfänglich und schnell genug kommen anne
gellinek
es sieht aus wie in einem kriegsfilm
aber die bilder sind echt panzer der von
russland unterstützten metzger
separatisten fahren durch die
außenbezirke der ukrainischen hafenstadt
mario pohl die sie offenbar in teilen
eingenommen haben eine stadt allerdings
die fast völlig zerstört ist es sind
diese bilder der verwüstung und die
mutmaßlicher kriegsverbrechen an
zivilisten die auch an europäischen
außenministern nicht spurlos
vorübergehen und nun zu einem umdenken
geführt haben europa will dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt und liefert
ab jetzt waffen töten können auch die
deutsche ministerin ist dafür die
ukraine braucht weiteres militärisches
material vor allen dingen auch schwere
waffen und jetzt ist keine zeit für
ausreden sondern jetzt ist zeit für
kreativität und pragmatismus
details nennt berbalk nicht aber
offenbar geht es um solche veralteten
und von der bundeswehr bereits
ausgemusterten kampfpanzer vom typ
leopard eines schnell geliefert werden
können auch sie nicht sie müssten
zunächst überholt und gewartet werden
das gleiche gilt für marder
schützenpanzer und panzerhaubitzen über
die ebenfalls spekuliert wird der
ukrainische präsident jens keller hatte
in seiner nächtlichen ansprache den
kurswechsel der deutschen regierung
bereits begrüßt ich bin froh
festzustellen dass sich die deutsche
position zur ukraine zum positiven
verändert hat ich finde das logisch denn
die mehrheit der deutschen steht hinter
der ukraine und dafür bin ich dem
deutschen volk dankbar
sie lenski fordert auch schärfere
sanktionen zb ein embargo gegen
russisches öl doch darüber wird bei den
außenministern kaum gestritten allen ist
klar dass ein lieferstopp gegen
deutschland nicht durchzusetzen ist für
diskussionsstoff dagegen sorgt die reise
des österreichischen kanzlers zu
wladimir putin nach russland es ist der
erste besuch eines europäischen
regierungschefs seit kriegsbeginn 1 75
minütiges streitgespräch ohne annäherung
sagt kanzler hammer am abend in moskau
es beginnt und immer etwas in so
direkten gesprächen dieser schonungslos
waren es war das kein
freundschaftsbesuch sondern ein klares
konfrontieren mit den fakten die aus der
ukraine krieg heraus resultieren es
braucht aus meiner sicht diese
persönliche konfrontation
ich glaube nicht dass wir mit putin
reden sollten widerspricht der
litauische außenminister es sei denn
über seine strafrechtliche verantwortung
für diesen
am abend steht die hafenstadt mariupol
offenbar kurz vor der eroberung durch
russland es gebe wohl keinen grund für
optimismus fast der österreichische
kanzler sein gespräch mit putin zusammen
angesichts dieser bilder klingt das noch
stark übertrieben
viele hintergründe zum krieg in der
ukraine finden sie natürlich auch online
auf zdf heute und nachher im
heute-journal update gibt es noch ein
interview mit dem cdu außenpolitiker
roderich kiesewetter
jetzt erstmal andere nachrichten des
tages von heinz boll in der diskussion
über alternativen zu energie importen
aus russland hat sich
wirtschaftsminister habeck gegen das
umstrittene fracking in deutschland
ausgesprochen also die förderung aus
schiefergestein er glaube dass das nicht
der weg sein den man gehen sollte sagte
arbeit in berlin zum einen würden
umfangreiche genehmigungen lange dauern
und in der akuten situation nicht
weiterhelfen außerdem wolle die
bundesregierung so schnell wie weg vom
möglichst schnell weg vom erdgas hin zu
erneuerbaren energien und wasserstoff
die eu ausbildungsmission in mali an der
bislang auch die bundeswehr beteiligt
ist soll weitgehend ausgesetzt werden
der eu außenbeauftragte borel teilte mit
es werde kein militärisches training
mehr geben
verteidigungsministerin lambrich die am
wochenende in mali war begrüßte den
vorläufigen ausbildungsstopp angesichts
möglicher massiver
menschenrechtsverletzungen die malische
truppen gemeinsam mit russischen kräften
womöglich sogar söldnern begangen haben
müssen wir uns fragen wen wir da
eigentlich ausbilden erklärte lamprecht
einer pandemie da sinkt laut robert koch
institut die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents weiter und liegt nun bei
1.080 dem lkw wurden 30
1789 neue corona fälle innerhalb eines
tages gemeldet 10 1340 weniger als
vergangenen montag außerdem kamen 13
todesfälle binnen 24 stunden hinzu
in der chinesischen metropole shanghai
erreichen die infektionszahlen neue
höchstwerte dennoch will die regierung
nun in einigen bereichen lockern nach
und nach werde es bewohnern in den
stadtteilen mit den niedrigsten
infektionen erlaubt ihre wohnungen
wieder zu verlassen teilte die
stadtverwaltung mit zuletzt hatte es
vermehrt kritik am strikten lockdown
gegeben es gab beschwerden etwa über
engpässe bei der lebensmittelversorgung
china erlebt derzeit den größten corona
ausbruch seit beginn der pandemie die
mit abstand meisten infektionen werden
in shanghai registriert
nach tagelanger politische krise ist in
pakistan oppositionsführers shahbaz
sharif zum neuen premierminister gewählt
worden eine mehrheit der abgeordneten im
parlament stimmte für den 70-jährigen
der bisherige regierungschef imran khan
war zuvor durch ein misstrauensvotum
abgesetzt worden in der nacht hatten
landesweit zehntausende gegen die
amtsenthebung des ehemaligen cricket
stars protestiert kan will die neue
regierung nicht anerkennen und kündigte
die organisation von massenprotesten an
um vorgezogene neuwahlen zu erzwingen
zuletzt war er wegen der schweren
wirtschaftskrise im land zunehmend unter
druck geraten
die berichte aus der ukraine über die
bombardierungen über die gräueltaten an
zivilisten wecken bei vielen menschen
hierzulande über das allgemeine grauen
hinaus ganz eigene persönliche
erinnerungen und traumata da ist zum
einen die kriegsgeneration die sich an
eigene erlebnisse zweiten weltkrieg
erinnert hinzu kommen menschen die in
den 90er jahren die balkankriege
erlebten und davor nach deutschland floh
ähnlich geht es geflüchteten aus syrien
zumal es sind städten wie alle pro jahr
auch russische luftangriffe gab sie
wissen genau was jetzt die ukraine durch
machen und sehen zugleich die
unterschiede im umgang mit den
flüchtenden motto sonne waldbericht
regelmäßig bringt mohammad al qaida
fahrräder kleider und kinderspielzeug
zur schul turnhalle in kirchseeon erste
aufnahmestelle in dieser bayerischen
gemeinde für ukrainische familien nach
ihrer flucht vor dem krieg
vor sieben jahren kam als kalaf selbst
hier an als flüchtlinge aus syrien
auch er ist vor bomben und zerstörung in
seiner heimat geflohen und vor dem
terror des islamischen staates dass er
jetzt den flüchtlingen aus der ukraine
hilft ist für ihn ganz
selbstverständlich
und die leute nette leute recht sieben
monate verbrachte mohammad al- kalaf im
jahr 2015 in dieser turnhalle gemeinsam
mit anderen geflüchteten jungen männern
aus arabischen und afrikanischen ländern
ehrenamtliche helfen ihnen auch mit der
sprache da sie erst das asylverfahren
durchlaufen mussten bis sie einen
deutschkurs besuchen durften hatte das
gefühl dass flüchtlinge aus der ukraine
ist heute leichter haben als er und
andere vor sieben jahren
sie wollen auch durch die helfen
hierdurch werden oder musik und sie sind
auch sie haben gleiche kultur und
kontakt das ist einfacher bei uns war es
sehr schwierig austausch mit dem landrat
der sich damals wie heute für die
schnelle und unkomplizierte aufnahme von
geflüchteten in seiner gemeinde einsetzt
er beobachtet dass die solidarität und
hilfsbereitschaft gegenüber ukrainischen
flüchtlingen größer ist als 2015 es gab
auch eine große welle der
hilfsbereitschaft aber eine andere
struktur die menschen aus der ukraine
wir wollen aber auch wieder zurück in
ihre heimat kommen mit dem auto hierher
mit auch mit ihren haustieren und die
menschen im landkreis sind sehr
hilfsbereit wenn man von 1500 menschen
die bei uns sind es sind 90 prozent
privat und über private bleibe statt
unterbringung im anker zentrum freie
einreise und bewegungsfreiheit stadt
langwierigem asylverfahren mit strikter
wohnsitz auflage vieles was heute für
geflüchtete aus der ukraine möglich ist
war 2015 noch undenkbar mit der so
genannten massenzustrom richtlinie
ermöglichen eu staaten jetzt millionen
von kriegsflüchtlingen aus der ukraine
schnellen und unbürokratischen schutz
bis zu drei jahren zugang zur
krankenversicherung
schulen und zum arbeitsmarkt
spielt es eine rolle dass uns menschen
aus der ukraine weniger fremd sind auf
jeden fall würde ich davon ausgehen dass
kulturelle und geographische nähe eine
rolle spielt und eine befragung der
universität warschau hat gezeigt dass
die polen die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
als nachbarn und als kollegen wahrnehmen
ein bis zweimal die woche besucht
mohammed al kalaf die integrationsklasse
der grundschule kirchseeon viele kinder
hier sind vor einem krieg in ihrer
heimat geflohen auch aus der ukraine wie
vielerorts sind auch in kirchseeon die
meisten ukrainischen flüchtlinge kinder
mit ihren müttern auch das spiel sicher
eine rolle für eine unterschiedliche
willkommenskultur heute und damals sagte
kallas ihm ist nur eines wichtig dass
diese jungen menschen hier nun in
frieden aufwachsen
1 macht weiter mit wirtschaft die
bundesregierung hat wegen der stark
gestiegenen energiepreise entlastungen
angekündigt wer davon wie viel hat dazu
hat ein institut der gewerkschaftsnahen
hans-böckler-stiftung eine studie
vorgelegt stephanie beckert mit welchen
ergebnissen nun es stand der vorwurf im
raum die sprit preissenkungen im
entlastungspaket könnten vor allem
besserverdiener und porsche-fahrer
begünstigen mit diesem vorurteil räumt
das gewerkschaftsnahe
wirtschaftsinstitut emk nun auf nach
dessen berechnungen kommen die geplanten
entlassungen durchaus bei denen an die
es dringend benötigen nämlich bei
haushalten mit niedrigen und mittleren
einkommen und bei familien so summieren
sich etwa bei einer familie mit zwei
kindern und monatlichem nettoeinkommen
von bis zu 2600 euro die einsparungen
auf 90 prozent der zusätzlichen
energiekosten
je höher das einkommen dann entsprechend
niedriger die entlastungen eine lücke
sehen die ökonomen bei rentnern und
rentnerinnen sie profitieren am
wenigsten vom staatlichen ausgleich
insgesamt soll aber für jeden bürger im
30 milliarden entlastungspaket etwas
dabei sein um die hohen energiekosten
abzufedern wie etwa die steuersenkung
auf sprit diese plant die
bundesregierung nun von anfang juni bis
ende august umzusetzen für denselben
zeitraum sollen nun auch die
vergünstigten tickets für busse und
bahnen im nahverkehr kommen und darüber
hinaus werden für alle die steuer
freibeträge erhöht und auch die
eeg-umlage fällt weg noch rasch ein
blick auf den dax der startet mit einer
leichten tristes in dieser woche es
belasten die frankreich wahl und die
auswirkungen der harten lockdown
maßnahmen in china
stefanie bareth vielen dank gern das dfb
team der frauen tritt morgen im wm
qualifikationsspiel gegen serbien
anzusehen ab 15.45 hier im zdf heute ist
die mannschaft in belgrad angekommen und
bereitet sich auf das morgige
zusammentreffen vor nach sieben siegen
in sieben gruppen spielen gelten die
deutschen frauen als favoritinnen
sollten sie auch dieses mal gewinnen
qualifizieren sie sich vorzeitig für die
wm 2022
kann und sollte man den künstler von
seiner kunst trennen die person vom werk
geht das überhaupt die frage wird eine
viel diskutierte bleiben bei richard
wagner ist sie das ja schon lange das
deutsche historische museum in berlin
unternimmt nun einmal mehr den versuch
sich dem wagner problem zu nähern und
zwar explizit auf der gefühlsebene so
auch der ausstellungstitel richard
wagner und das deutsche gefühl die
gefühle von wagner und für wagner werden
dabei in vier kategorien aufgeteilt
entfremdung zugehörigkeit eros und ekel
wobei sich letzteres nicht nur auf
seinen notorischen antisemitismus
bezieht stefan nase poker
alle jahre wieder pilgern sie nach
bayreuth um dem titanen zu huldigen hier
ließ er seinen eigenen musiktempel
erbauen in dem ausschließlich die werke
des großen meisters aufgeführt werden
dürfen so
es verfügt
richard wagner verehrt und verabscheut
eine welthistorische figur er hat die
musik revolutioniert war aber auch
nationalist und antisemit
auf der einen seite musik auf der
anderen seite geschichte und politik und
für mich war es unglaublich wichtig und
interessant und faszinierend weil diese
beiden ebenen kommen immer zu sagen
warten erlebte ausschweifend liebte
luxus wie dieser seine hausschuhe
bezeugt er betrug seine ehefrauen und
machte schulden seinen mit zehn ludwig
den zweiten von bayern kostete er ein
vermögen wagner war nationalist widmete
reichsgründer bismarck ein gedicht und
schrieb dem deutschen kaiser einen macht
ich bin der deutscheste mensch schrieb
er in sein tagebuch deutsch musste
seinem verständnis nach auch musik sei
musik für wagner ist die kunst der
innerlichkeit also die kunst der der
gefühle und nur deutsche haben die
fähigkeit eine tiefe dichterische
innerlichkeit zu haben und deswegen für
wagner ist musik wesentlich eine
deutsche kunst und eine deutsche
fähigkeit
warten als deutsches gefühl verabscheut
die französische und die italienische
oper in seiner hetzschrift das judentum
in der musik spricht er den jüdischen
komponisten felix mendelssohn bartholdy
ab tiefe zu haben herz und seele zu
berühren und das obwohl mendelsohn
wagner inspirierte und beeinflusste
ordner ist tatsächlich ein erfinder des
modernen antisemitismus
das heißt dass rassistischen
antisemitismus und da sagen beschwerung
einen großen unterschied zwischen diesen
zwei
rassismus hat immer mit körpern zu tun
weder die zwerge alberich und mime aus
dem ring der nibelungen noch beckmesser
aus den meistersingern sind jüdische
figuren und doch können sie als juden
karikaturen bedeutet werden ist wagners
werk in teilen antisemitisch
was das für seine kunst bedeutet ich
glaube das wird offen bleiben und das
ist ein großer streit und der es
hochspannend
richard warte und das deutsche gefühl
eine einladung das werk und den menschen
zusammen zu denken
[Musik]
das was an uns gleich nach dem wetter
geht's mit dem montagskino weiter und um
0 uhr meldet sich dann gundula gause mit
dem politischen update ist morgen auf
wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter der satellit film
von heute zeigt bei uns hohem luftdruck
aber auch hohe wolkenfelder die kommen
mit dem tief über dem atlantik zu uns
das ist hier quasi festgetackert und
schiebt immer wieder wolken aber auch
warme luft aus nordafrika zu uns da ist
auch saharastaub dabei in der nacht wird
es im osten deutschlands aufklaren hier
also sternenklarer himmel sonst harmlose
wolken insgesamt trockenes wetter bei
tiefsten temperaturen im osten
deutschlands bis minus 4 grad in bayern
gibt es bis auf minus 1 grad runter am
niederrhein auf 8 grad plus morgen dann
im tagesverlauf viel sonne vor allem am
alpenrand und in bayern nach südwesten
hin ebenfalls viel sonnenschein aber
hier hohe wolkenfelder da ist auch
saharastaub durchaus möglich nach norden
hin sind die wolken kompakter insgesamt
aber trockenes wetter die höchsten
temperaturen nach nordosten hin bei 11
bis 15 grad hier ist es am kühlsten
sonst wird es aber deutlich wärmer vor
allem im südwesten bis 23 grad in den
westlichen landesteilen liegt die
temperatur meist um die 20 grad marke
schauen wir auf die nächsten tage und es
wird am mittwoch wärmer bis 24 grad aber
eine kaltfront stört im nordwesten sind
ein schauer und gewitter dabei am
donnerstag verlagert sich das ganze ein
wenig weiter richtung südosten bei 22
grad am karfreitag ist vor allem im
norden recht kühl nach süden etwas
milder bei 20 grad ein schöner abend